welcome back to the David Pakman show. Welcome
back to the David Pakman show. I am Farron
cousins sitting in for David Pakman today.
You can follow me on Twitter at Farron
balanced, f. A. R. R. O. N. B. A. L. A. N.
C. E. D. It's the same on Instagram and on
Facebook. Let's jump back into the dues. Now.
Let's get to the Democrats. Right.
This past weekend, Bernie Sanders on meet
the press said something that I could not
agree more with, and I know later in the weekend
also, Bernie Sanders said some things that
were really insensitive, but I got to talk
about this issue here because I think this
really hits the nail on the head with what
the 2020 campaign has to be about. Bernie
Sanders during his Sunday appearance on meet
the press was asked about Joe Biden's comment
while campaigning a day or two before where
Joe Biden was asked about his climate policy
and he said, I'll tell you what my climate
policy is. Number one, you gotta beat Donald
Trump. Everybody laughed. Everybody applauded
because that was Joe Biden's really answer.
You want to make things better in this country,
defeat Donald Trump. So Bernie Sanders comes
along on meet the press on Sunday. It says,
listen, Trump cannot be the only goal of 2020
2020 cannot just be about beating Donald Trump.
Here's his exact quote here, says, beating
Trump is not good enough. You have to beat
the fossil fuel industry. You have to take
on all the forces of the status quo who do
not want to move this country to energy efficiency
and sustainable energy. Now that's just on
the issue of climate change, right? But here
we've seen it from Bernie. We have seen it
from Kamala Harris, we've seen it from Elizabeth
Warren. We have seen it from so many other
people. Andrew Yang, Tulsi, Gabard, even people
dead judge people who actually come out with
policy. Nobody more. So, by the way, then
Elizabeth Warren.
Yeah,
but Biden's just out there saying, oh, we
want to do anything about these. We gotta
beat Trump because Biden is still clinging
onto to those poles are those beliefs or whatever
they are that he's the only one who can beat
Donald Trump. And that's why we got to put
all our faith in him. Policy will come later.
Don't worry about that. In fact, about a week
ago, Biden also told us he didn't have time
to explain his healthcare policy. I got to
move on. I gotta worry about beating Donald
Trump. You cannot, and I can't stress this
enough. You can't beat Donald Trump if you're
not out there offering policies. Because I
know it's easy to get swept up in the big
crowds at these, uh, you know, campaign events.
The people cheering on these talking points
about beating Donald Trump. You see it on
Twitter. We've got to be Trump. That's not
the whole country though, folks.
That's not the average person going about
their lives in their homes. Because believe
it or not, a lot of people in this country
have not been adversely affected by Donald
Trump's policies. They're not benefiting in
any way from them. Don't get me wrong, but
they haven't exactly affected their day to
day lives. You know, their paychecks haven't
increased, but they haven't decreased. So
why would I jump ship? Things are okay for
me personally. Why would I want to change
this? Why would I want to risk it? And that's
what Democrats have to do a better job of
explaining. And by Democrats, I mean all,
I don't know, 85 who are running for president.
We've got plenty who are explaining Sanders,
Warren, uh, Harris Yang. These people are
out there and Tulsa Gabbert again, they're
out there telling us like, this is what I
want to do and this is how it's going to affect
you.
And again, nobody's doing that better than
Elizabeth Warren, which is why her poll numbers
are finally starting to tick up there a little
bit. But listen, I'm not advocating for one
candidate or the other at this point, and
I'm not trying to discourage voting for anyone
except maybe Biden at this point because we're
still in the primaries and I can do that without
worrying if you like Biden, fine, but why?
And be expected to answer that question. What
is Biden offering that is going to make your
life better? And don't just say he's going
to beat Trump. That's a cop out. That is a
very weak answer with no substance behind
it because there's really not much evidence
to suggest that Biden will beat Trump. Oh,
you want to look at the polling data, the
same polling data that said that Hillary Clinton
was going to run away with this thing in 2016
be my guest.
But if you're putting all your faith in that
than be expected, you know, you can go ahead
and expect the same kind of disappointment
you had in 2016 what we need to be talking
about, what every candidate needs to be talking
about is hard policy, not just ideas either.
You've got to have, again, I'm gonna Use Elizabeth
Warren as the example because she has done
it better than anybody else. You have to have
the roadmap, you have to explain how we get
from a to B to c to d to the end goal, all
the way, every step of the process. You have
to be prepared for the Republican obstruction
and you have to understand and have a plan
to counter that because Republicans aren't
gonna let these big ideas go through the green
new deal. The medicare for all the $15 living
wage ain't gonna happen under the Republican's
Watch. So you better have a work around and
of course you are 100% certain that Democrats
are going to retain the house and take back
the Senate in 2020 it's all possible. By the
way, there are far more republicans up for
reelection. Then there are Democrats in the
Senate. We could do this. We absolutely could
do this.
Yeah,
but not if you're just out there saying, vote
for me because I'm not Trump. We tried that
in 2016 and it failed. What did Trump do that
was different? Well, we know who has bases
and we know why they supported him. They they
like white people and nobody else. We get
that part. But there are plenty of Trump voters
who, believe it or not, not racist, average
normal working class folks.
Yeah,
and he was talking policy. He was talking
ideas, bad ideas and bad policies that he
had no intention of following through on.
Buddy talked about it folks, and I think people
miss that in these conversations and I think
most of the Democrats who are running for
president understand that they don't need
this lecture. They don't need to hear me tell
them to talk about policy because they are.
You can go to their websites and find every
possible issue under the sun and find out
what they want to do and how they're going
to do it. But then there's Biden. Biden wants
to come out, be the happy, feel good candidate,
be the maybe a little too touchy feely candidate,
but he wants you to vote for him because he's
not Donald Trump. And I'll be 100% right now.
I'm in Florida, a swing state. I don't have
the luxury of a protest vote. If Biden ends
up securing the Democratic nomination, I'm
a vote from for Biden. I'm Gunna, I'm going
to hold him accountable. If he does something
bad, I'm going to report on it.
But if that's my only option, I'll vote for
Biden. I'm not going to stay home. I'm not
gonna write in somebody who doesn't have a
chance, because again, I'm in a swing state.
Very tough swing state too. But until we get
to that point where a single person is sealed
the deal on who the Democratic nominee is
going to be, I'm going to hold them all accountable.
When Bernie Sanders screws up, I'm gonna call
them out. When Elizabeth Warren does, I'm
going to call her. Same thing with Harrison
Booker and boots, edge edge. And I have, and
I do and I will because that's our job.
It should not be the job of any pond. It youtuber,
progressive hosts. It shouldn't be anybody's
job to just promote a single candidate, promote
the issues and find the candidate that fits
those the best. Yeah, we've got some great
people running for president and I do have
actually two people in my head that right
now I don't know which one of them I'm going
to vote for. I love them both. I think they're
both great and I think either one of them
would be a phenomenal transformative figure
in that White House. So I don't know yet.
But what I do know is that I'm going to hold
these and every one of these people accountable
and when they come off off message, when they
start with the stupid talk of, Oh my climate
policy is to beat Donald Trump. Hahaha, that's
not good enough. That's not going to win my
support in any way, shape or form.
Climate policy is climate policy beating Trump
is just part of that goal. I want to know
how you're gonna fix the planet. You know,
we were told we had 12 years before we get
to the irreparable damage part of climate
change. But keep in mind that was over six
months ago folks over six months ago. So for
Biden to go out there, and even if he was
making a joke, you can't joke about things
like this right now because yeah, it's pretty
bad. We can fix it. We 100% could fix it and
reverse it and live long happy lives. We talked
about in history books as the time when humanity
came together and fix the problem or we could
be known as the ones who continue to let it
get worse, which is what's happening now.
We no longer have 12 years, more like 11 and
a half, probably closer to 11 considering
that emissions have increased and carbon in
the atmosphere has increased.
So that's kind of cutting that clock down
a little bit. But don't joke about the best
way to solve the climate crisis is to defeat
Donald Trump. As Bernie Sanders said, the
best way to defeat the climate crisis is to
defeat the fossil fuel interests, to defeat
the big money fighting climate change policy.
2020 is not just about Donald Trump and any
Democrat who tells you that is not worthy
of your primary vote